Serena do you want to pick one up
uh I've never touched it this was a
training scene I like dogs too if you
pick Alexis I'll pick one up if you pick
one up
very tightly there we go
and so they actually get security from
knowing that they're held closely so so
they won't pick you
but
that's done yeah look at those feet
she's just saying hello all right there
you go what's the cow's name the steer's
name Antonio Enrique Cortez uh leche
Serena that's the name of the cow I
missed a couple of them Antonio who
Antonio for Antonio Banderas okay
Enrique for Enrique Iglesias Cortez
because it was why we were watching the
Spy Kids movie okay yeah and that was
the last name it looks like it's movie
so I let the kids
you know and he has a few other names